hey Gary John Lee Dumas entrepreneur on
fire here in I've a hashtag askgaryvee
question Pareto's law states that 80% of
our desired outcomes come from just 20%
of our activities do you agree with this
if so what's your 20 that's a great
question I think a lot of people have
brought that up I know a lot of people
in our organization believe in that I
put a lot of people believe in that you
know do I believe in that and what is
might one junk first of all Congrats on
your podcast um you know I I probably
think weirdly enough that it might even
be more extreme there's a big part of me
that thinks it's probably closer to 98
and to then there's another part of me
that believes that it's 2 and 98 I am
the kind of person that doesn't give a
crap about other people's laws or
principles what feels right for me is
execution I think when people start
knowing you know this is kind of what I
talk about my my naivete or lack of
knowledge helps me I think if I knew
about this law prior to you bringing it
up I mean I've heard about the 80/20
rule that I have no official name if I
knew about this law it would actually
make me want to play within that law and
then that would probably take away from
the strength that I create every day I
mean people ask me what the ROI of the
askgaryvee show is a couple episodes ago
new Hardcore watches know that i say
well this is selling my fourth book
here's what I think I think human beings
overthink [ __ ] right and try to buy into
some sort of thesis read a book it makes
them feel good whether it's crush it or
Peru doze law or whatever it's called
and I think that is a fundamental
problem I think when we start coming
from what's authentic and what feels
more natural you know the law I believe
in is that my mom and dad had sex at a
moment created me and I'm taking this
DNA to the finish line that ball that's
the law I believe it oh crap wait
subscribe I need subscriptions because I
can't push this many right hooks in
social so subscribe